My wife and kids are quick to anger.
Sometimes it's explosive like
the Moab mother of all bombs.
Other times it's a slow
grinding war of attrition.
Being a student of your podcasts,
I've learned the worst strategy is to
directly attack there four to fight
emotional position.
It seems like this is a good opportunity
to employ the flanking maneuver.
How do I effectively flank their
anger without appearing weak?
Okay, first of all, flank yourself
cause that appearing weak thing.
That's pretty much in your head really.
It is slow generally in your head and
that's the first thing you need to do is
that's your ego talking when you
don't want to, when you don't want to,
when they hit you with
something that they're angry at,
the thing that's hitting back his ego,
that's what's hitting back.
So first thing you gotta do is,
okay,
I'm going to check my ego right now cause
I'm going to win the long war. In fact,
you have to be careful when you stay calm,
when everyone else is angry.
You have to actually be careful not
to come across as aloof or you know,
arrogant. Yeah, yeah. Like when people
are getting mad. Okay. Okay. For instance,
if your wife is super mad about something
and you show no emotions and you don't
get mad at all, they get
matter sometimes, right? Yeah.
You don't even care about this,
you know, so no, no. So you got up,
you got to give a little bit.
You know,
I'm not saying it a little
bit of hey I get it.
Right, but then which one do is
absorb? Oh they want to get mad. Cool.
Absorb.
Take the screaming,
give the head nod of understanding in
a more only marginally emotional way.
That pretty much communicates that.
I understand you're mad and I'm,
I'm listening and I hear you.
You know I get it.
And let them get it out of their system.
This, let them get an honors system.
Then let them calm down.
And then after you've given them the
time to kind of calm down and settle down
and I mean it's a longer than you think.
It's longer than you think. Let them
let, let when you think they're calm,
wait an extra 45 minutes if not two hours,
probably two hours.
Cause they're not called to be safe.
They just stopped screaming. Right.
They're all so,
and then what you do is,
and then what you do is you kind of take
it on yourself. You're going to own it,
right? And you say something like, Hey,
you know that thing that made you mad.
I want to make sure it doesn't
happen again. Right. You don't walk.
What can I do better to make sure that
you don't get mad about that. Right.
You take,
you take ownership of that.
What do I need to adjust
and what exactly is it that,
that I did that frustrated.
What is it that frustrates you?
What can I do to stop it? Maybe it wasn't
me. Maybe you're mad at the printer,
but you know, how can we fix that?
Because I don't want you to do.
And then you know,
so you have the,
that kind of conversation and you know,
you're going to slide something tactfully
and their tactfully because again,
you're still dealing with like,
you know,
possible flare up scenarios
happening. So you know, but you,
but you say something like that,
you know,
we both know that nobody benefits when
people lose their temper. Right? I mean,
we gotta be careful, you
know, no one, it's not,
it doesn't do us any good when people lose
their temper, we, everyone knows that.
Right?
So you slide those things in there.
You're given that kind of like a little
mini lecture indirectly about what's
happening. And then when you
have other conversations,
now we're in just a normal day to day
thing. You drop things about temper,
you know, you talk about
temporary being, well, you know,
it's a weakness and it's no one
makes good decisions when they have,
when they lose their temper,
everything.
So some of the dumbest things I've
ever done was when I logged, you know,
everyone knows that you see,
you start sliding those things in there
that it's bad for your decision making.
It's bad for relationships, it's bad for
your health, it's bad for life. And again,
you're not directly saying these things.
You're subliminally saying even,
you know, it's man, I
remember one time I lost him.
This little dumbest things I ever did
when I lost my temper and I kicked the
wall and I broke my toe and I put a hole
in the wall and the landlord came. I,
that's when I,
I hate when I lose my temper.
And you start getting them in the,
even thinking about it over time,
and this is the thing,
it's a long war and there's going
to be relapses along the way,
but you got to just hold the line,
keep it steady,
absorb and then f flank gently to get
them to start self recognizing where
they're at and what their temper
does. Tone tempers crazy. Yeah.
And you see people lose their temper.
It's, it's a total loss of control. Yeah.
It's a total loss control and it's
just doesn't do anybody any good.
And when you see someone that really
loses their temper, you're like,
what is wrong? Come on. Yeah.
And when I was a kid and I used to
lose my temper and at some point I just
realized,
I forget what it was.
I forget what made me think there
was something my dad said to me,
there's something about, you know,
something along those lines of like, yeah,
you lose your temper. It's like a
little baby. Oh, loss of control. Okay.
So you, you, when you realized it,
that's because of something your dad,
my dad said to me something along
the lines of like, you know,
I think he was referring
to an athlete or something,
someone that just had no emotions
and how that was impressive. Yeah.
And I was like, hmm, that is
impressive. Massive control one,
nothing is going to make me mad. Yeah.
Doesn't matter what's going on around me.
Yeah. Yeah. It is like a baby, you know,
like I said, you know, like babies,
they cry and they whatever,
cause they don't know how to talk.
So if they knew how to talk and control
everything, just be like, Hey, I'm colt.
Or Hey, I'm hungry. But they
didn't know how to talk.
So why do adults go crazy
and cry because their babies,
because they don't know
how to talk if they,
if they kind of for every little
thing, they're babies. Yeah.
They don't know how to talk. I said,
actually, you know what under, um,
and it depends. That depends how much
controlling in all these little variables,
but it's
like the front part of your brain that's
a decision making like the conscious
like okay, I'm going to make this
dis this conscious decision, right?
Which is the last part of your
brain to develop that way.
And it's like a conscious
decision making by the front,
the like frontal lobe Cortex,
you know, something like this.
And it happens and it fully
develops around age 25 by the way.
So if you're (242) 032-0220 one at all.
And so put simply, it's like, okay,
my actions now how do they
affect the future? You know?
So in one way or another,
it's going to be kind of surrounded on
that little premise, small little pro.
So otherwise you're just going on
straight auto mode, however you,
however you feel that's going to
influence, not totally control,
but that's the thing that's going
to influence your behaviors.
So Times of stress, your frontal
cortex start to shut down a little bit.
Hunger shut down a little bit.
Uh,
hormonal situations for guys and girls.
Oh, so you lose your temper more.
That's where angry comes from.
Hangry is one of them, you know,
and it's like all these
things, loss, empathy,
loss of like all this stuff where your
decisions just aren't that dope. Yeah.
And so, and when I say hormonal,
like that's why you get roid rage.
You don't look good. Cause like
guys, if they're on steroids,
that's their hormones are up.
Or girls pms scene.
It's like a real, you know,
premenstrual syndrome. It's like a road.
Their hormones are all still,
I remember one time my wife
started when she was pregnant,
she started crying during an 18
and t commercial. Like legit.
I was like, oh my gosh, what's wrong
with her? Some of those are kind of sad,
emotional nonetheless there. Why were
you crying during Hawaii? Five O oh man.
I'm telling you. They're trying,
they're trying to make it deep man,
that show you're watching him.
Nadise anyway, nonetheless. Um,
it's back to losing your temper and stuff.
It is a week thing. So it's kind of
obvious, especially from the outside,
to see that look, this losing your
temper is not cool. And a lot of people,
they think it's cool
because it feels good.
It feels good when you're a little kid,
you respect it because you see someone
lose their temper, you, you scared.
It's like turning into superman.
Right?
[inaudible] mean he's feared,
but right.
You're not feared by you look stupid.
Yes.
If that's the message to convey to your
kiss. Yeah. Losing your temper. Stupid.
Yeah. And Man, some people there,
you could tell they say that stuff
with a little bit of pride, you know,
it's just me and my temporary tempers
going to get me in trouble and they're all
like, yeah, you're not proud.
I'm a dead man. That's like me.
That should be the guy I wish I didn't.
That should be, if you say, Hey,
I just have a temper, that should
be the equivalent of you saying,
I don't know how to read it should
be that, hey, nothing wrong with it.
You can get past it and
you know, whatever. I'm not
going to judge you for it,
but it's not good.
It's not a good state to be in boot.
Someone who can't control your temper,
just like it's not a good state to be
in as a grown adult to not know how to
read no judgment,
but you solve that problem.
That's a B.
If you're having like if your kids have
a temper and they're easy to anger,
it's because chances are I
don't know everybody of course,
but chances are they
got it from the parents.
Keep in mind you're one of those parents.
I'm not saying,
I'm not saying that you have a temper,
I'm not saying you don't,
but I am seeing sure kids have a temper.
Your wife as a temporary,
you got it. Really honestly, evaluate.
Do I have a temper and
understand that cause the kids,
they're just these little seeds of
beings who are like, hey, how do I act?
I don't know how to act all act, how you
know just how I feel. I'm going to cry.
This is my default. I'm just going
to cry when something's right.
So you're saying that for the parents
have a temper and show that knack,
that way the kids will learn it from them.
You're going to learn it.
So there is some theory or something
like genetic though I thought,
well maybe I guess it could.
We don't know if it's genetic or not,
but there are some where you know the
father has a bad temper and then the kid
has a bad temper. Yeah, temper gene.
So what it is is there's the genetic
situation for sure at that you're more apt
to not be able to
control certain parts of,
or not not be able to control
but control less. You know,
certain parts of your brain or chemistry
is going to make you lean towards
certain types of behavior, like impulsive
behavior or something like that.
There is that for sure. But
again, man, when you're a kid,
you're just looking for how do I
act? I don't know. I'm growing up.
I don't even know how to act.
So the first thing you're
going to look at is the people,
the Authority figures in front of you,
the parents. If the parents aren't there,
who are they looking to? I don't know.
The guy next door, the guy on TV,
the guy up the street, the guy in the
music video, whoever. I don't know.
Whoever's doing better than me.
That's it.
So if you're the parent and you're
losing your temper all the time,
kids going to lose their
temper. That's how, what?
They're going to learn how
to act. So point there is
if you lose your temporary or if
your kids are losing the Internet,
you start with yourself
because you know the crime,
you know,
kind of,
there's certain things that's real easy
to see when someone else does it or yeah,
most things. But yeah. But it's
really, yeah. You simply don't see,
it sounds like this guy here
that asks this question,
he's saying his wife loses his temper and
that could be where the kid is getting
that, that modeling from. Right,
right. And he's saying he doesn't.
Now is there a chance that he
does to private? I guess so.
But it sounds like he's pretty
together and he's saying, look,
I just need to get them to calm down.
Right. So yeah, in this situation,
I'd say it's probably the wife who's
losing her temper and then the kid is
imitating or modeling,
and then we have this scenario happening.
So what we need to do is explain to
everyone in the family that it's not good.
We're not losing our tempers anymore.
They, yeah. And the reason I say it to is,
again, I, I'm not saying
he does lose his temper,
but I am saying that it is a possibility
that because if let's say mean,
and your husband and wife and I
bought were just bruised. Yeah.
Well we're worried, you know, it's life.
Me and my wife. Okay. If she
loses the temper, her temper,
and I'm taking the direct
approach, right? Yeah.
Which I understand you're now temper more
all, I'm going to lose my temper back.
I'm going to go fire. I'm going to fight
fire with fire. You raise your voice.
I'm gonna raise my voice. The kids over
there in the corner. How do I act? Oh,
that's how I act right there.
That's a possibility.
And kids will become antisocial.
That's the thing goes on.
It's one of the things,
one of the many things anti social,
I told you about that book called
Mind Games. Small little book.
I forget the author like pretty clearly
and concisely laid out if you have anger
issues like what up with that?
It's an insecurity changed my whole life.
Low self esteem.